foreign
let's chat if you're open to it about
Kickstarter for a moment because I know
a lot of people outside of
games specifically will still be
interested in Kickstarter or
crowdfunding in general
so you I believe at one point had a
fraud alert email printed out and framed
because I think somewhere the limo was
set like 10 000 and maybe it got bumped
like 50 000 for this new bank account
for things yeah what was your initial
Target for the kickstarter campaign and
where did you end up the initial Target
was we were trying to raise ten thousand
dollars in 30 days
and we set that alert like the bank
would let us deposit a check up to fifty
thousand dollars they were being very
generous and the check that we tried to
deposit at the end of those 30 days was
almost nine million dollars
okay I have specific questions
around how you did things differently
and you had some some very strong
advantages going in right you had your
background you had matte and the oatmeal
and all the followers of the oatmeal
yeah so you had
you had a deck that was loaded in a
sense but still ended up being maybe
still is the most backed in terms of
number of backers Kickstarter project or
at least at the time that was the case
still the case by a lot actually in
order to talk about Kickstarter we have
to talk about two things one is
alternate reality games and the other is
the oatmeal yep so alternate reality
games like my background being sort of
trained at Microsoft and at the Xbox and
learning about communities and the
appeal of games and and why we play
games together
I then went off and started with some
friends this company to build alternate
reality games and all you really need to
know about alternate reality games
although I could talk about them for a
long time is
the central premise is
together you are stronger together as a
community you can do stuff you can
become extraordinary versions of
yourselves and the games are set up to
deliver a story out in the real world
that is convoluted
and you have to piece it back together
it's like my my mentor Jordan Weissman
likes to call it internet archeology so
archeology is
you find all the little bits and pieces
of the vas you put it together in order
to figure out what it is about that
Society how that Society lived how those
people lived
alternate reality games are the same
thing we write a beautiful Story start
to finish
with a very compelling narrative and
then we break it up into little pieces
and we hide those pieces everywhere in
the real world on the internet on phone
lines fax lines live actors everywhere
and you the audience working together
because you're stronger together go and
perform that feat of archeology find all
the pieces put them back together look
at your beautiful digital vas and then
learn the story
based on based on what you found
so I built a lot of those and I was
really trained
over and over again really beaten into
my psyche Community First Community
First they're so much smarter than you
are learn to entertain a crowd that's
what this is all about
all right
we decided to launch this Kickstarter
campaign we had this really
compelling hook we knew the game was
really good we put up the page and the
very first thing that happens is the
oatmeal goes into full effect Matt has
spent at that point about a decade
building an audience earning their trust
convincing them that like he does just
really high quality work and for those
who don't know could you did just
explain what the oatmeal yes so at that
point what it looked like yeah so at
that point the oatmeal was and still is
a web page the oatmeal.com and Matt has
spent 10 years writing short form comedy
one panel sometimes up to four panel
Comics very few long-form pieces where
he tells stories about his childhood or
he it's a lot of social commentary and
they're hilarious they're beautiful some
of them have won Eisner Awards they will
make you cry
he is Matt is truly one of the most
talented artists and comedians I've ever
met and yeah he's a guy who's just so
much smarter than I am it's an
incredible collaboration and I got to
meet him through a mutual friend I
pitched this game to him we talked about
it he said he'd really like to help and
and off we went and when we launched the
kickstarter campaign honestly it was
only like three weeks after I met him
wow that's fast yeah really fast we
built this didn't realize that was yeah
that it was that fast we built it fast
because we had nothing to lose we we
didn't think it would be a huge success
we just thought this feels really good
we don't have to overthink this let's
just go is it fair to say that also at
that point you had the game mechanics
refined
and Matt was bringing in
a lot of the sort of artistic comedic
Flair in terms of the back hair cards
and the artwork so you're effectively
adding art to game mechanics that we're
ready to go yeah but kind of lacked an
artistic vehicle yeah totally fair there
are 56 cards in the game and so Matt's
task was not to design the game although
we both worked hard to to refine it
Matt's task was write 56 one panel jokes
and and he did like you flip through
that deck and the first thing you're
going to do is just just laugh I mean
it's it's such beautiful art yeah
okay so back to our story we launched
the kickstarter campaign and Matt posted
about it he says for the first time ever
I've done a game I hope you like it and
millions of people showed up like like
literally millions of views to that
Kickstarter page and our first we got
funded we're trying to raise ten
thousand dollars we got funded in like
seven minutes I mean it was it was out
of control and our first day we made a
million dollars and our second day we
had two million in our third day we had
three million and it was just like this
is this is a runaway train like we have
certainly caught lightning in a bottle
we've we've we have unleashed the full
potential of the oatmeal here's finally
a way to productize that incredible
brand welcome exploding kittens to the
world
but then after the first week
after the first week it fell off a cliff
and the reason is is just because
everyone who Matt could reach who was
interested in this thing had taken a
look either made a purchase decision or
not and that was it you know the the
tank was empty
so
I sat down with him and we're like well
we got two choices we can either just
sort of ride off into the sunset and say
we made like four million bucks that's
incredible we're trying to raise ten
thousand let's just you know Take a Bow
and and we're done
or we could try to push this thing a
little bit and and just see what else is
possible on Kickstarter and I kind of
at the time
wow this is long-winded but I guess so
so into this stuff so bear with me
at the time the way that Kickstarter
worked the kind of only lever you had
were these things called stretch goals
and the way a stretch goal works is you
say look I got this product I'm gonna
charge you 20 bucks for it
and we're gonna try to raise ten
thousand dollars but if we raise twenty
thousand dollars for free everybody gets
three more bonus cards and if we raise
fifty thousand dollars you get a
carrying case and if we raise a hundred
thousand dollars you know you gold
plated cards whatever it is
that was the tool you had give us more
money we'll give you more [__]
we decided that's going to be the name
of this podcast episode
when we looked at that ecosystem with
that one lever give us more money we'll
give you more [__]
we kind of thought like there's got to
be something else we can do there's got
to be something else and I I suddenly
like my eyes went wide and I realized
holy crap I've been training for this
moment my whole damn life yeah like we
need to activate the community instead
of thinking this is you know crowd
funding let's think of this as crowd
funding right yeah so we did Stretch
goals just like everybody else but
instead of tying it to money we tied it
to
just insane [__] that we could ask the
backers to do we basically said look
we're going to throw a party and
everybody's invited
instead of giving us more money we're
done with money instead hey we got this
character in our game called taco cat
half cat half Taco show us a picture of
a real taco cat
and if you do if like 10 people do that
we'll throw in 10 extra cards that's a
stretch goal you know it would be funny
give us a picture of 10 Batmans in a hot
tub whatever the hell that means we want
to see it somebody does that we'll give
you a fancy carrying case and we just
went nuts we wrote These challenges that
were insane and and funny and
basically said we we just want to have
fun please have fun with us this is
going to be we're only here for another
20 days so why don't we just celebrate
the whole way through
and the audience jumped on it and they
they did everything we asked they they
took those pictures and they wrote poems
they filmed videos they went out on the
streets they met each other they had
they had parties together they ordered
pizza like all the fun stuff because we
basically said money doesn't matter
anymore let's just have fun and it was a
great invitation